If I have to take an antibiotic, what should I do to help with my gut?
Well, the study's out there. If you have to take an antibiotic, let's say you have an acute infection,
you have a bladder infection, you have a strep infection, you have to take an antibiotic, you just have a tick bite
and you look like it's inflamed, look nasty.
There's issues with it and you have to take an antibiotic.
All the studies that are out there say if you take a probiotic at the same time you're taking an antibiotic,
that's the key to the most protective measure.
When you're on the end of a sp people think, well, I'll start taking a probiotic after I'm done with this five days of antibiotic.
Well, the study shows if you take it with your antibiotic, which I would say take one with each antibiotic pill
and take one of the afternoon and off a couple hours away from the antibiotic, take several antibiotics
when you're taking it antibiotic, does far a better job than waiting until you're done with the antibiotic.
So take a probiotic with your antibiotic.
The other things you could do after you're done is take some gut healing products.
So different things like deglycerized licorice, slippery, elm, marshmallow, things like that can be extremely healing
to the gut products like immunoglobulins like SBI Protect can be healing to the gut and clean it out.
Buterate products can help with initiating gut healing.
So there's a lot of gut protective things that you could do and things you could do post antibiotic use as well.